my cousin Vinnie is almost indisputably
the best legal comedy ever made and it's
absolutely hilarious but it's also
incredibly realistic and I sat down with
Dale lonner the writer of my cousin
Vinnie to find out all the secrets of
how he wrote it and how he got it right
now by the way there is a special
extended version of this interview that
is almost twice as long available only
on nebula which you can access at the
link below what was the premise of the
sequel curtains open up and we're in the
Old Bailey and we see Vinnie and he's
carrying a brown paper bag and Vinnie
takes off his his jacket puts it in the
paperback and then pulls something out
of there which is a Barrister's robe and
then he pulls on a Barrister's wig then
the defendant is brought in and it's
Mona Lisa Vito you think I'm hostile now
wait till you see me tonight
[Music]
Legal Eagles today today we are going to
learn all the secrets of one of if not
the best legal comedy of all time my
cousin Vinnie because we are here with
none other than the writer of my cousin
Vinnie Dale honor Dale thank you so much
for joining us and uh for for giving us
your time here great looking forward to
it so I almost don't know where to start
because lawyers and and I think lay
people love my cousin Vinnie uh it's
it's a classic both a classic movie and
one of the greatest legal movies of all
time
um let's I guess start with your
background you are an extremely
accomplished screenwriter how did you
get started where did that come from I
liked movies and I remember talking to a
friend of mine
and she asked me what'd you do last
night so I said well I went to a movie
and she said you go to a lot of movies
and I feel a little guilty about that I
guess I felt like a twinge of Shame for
going to so many movies you know and
and then I felt why should I be ashamed
I like movies and I remember in college
there were so many different majors
and there was something called radio TV
film right and I thought boy if I was an
rtvf major if I was a film major
I could go all the movies I want without
shame right as a matter of fact I would
have to make a concerted effort to see
more movies and that would be like
homework research and that's what I did
is I mean I changed my major and my
grades shot up and then I was inspired
by Woody Allen's Take the Money and Run
I was inspired because I didn't think it
was that good anything was that funny
and I thought I could do that I wasn't
sure if I could be funnier but I think
it'd be that funny
well let's let's talk about my cousin
Vinnie itself where did that idea come
from
when I was 19 I went backpacking through
Europe you would meet different people
from around the world and I met actually
uh a couple of girls from La they were
older women 25 year old girls
and one was it was Andy reefman we
remained friends and when I came back to
LA I met her fiance Fred Fenster Fred
told her why don't you take a trip to
Europe I need to study for the bar and
so when I met him he had taken the bar
and I asked Fred what happens if you
don't pass he says you take it again
what if you don't pass that take it
again
well how many times can you take it as
many times as you want well how many
times does somebody take it failed and
finally passed and he says 13 times I
find it interesting how law students
seem to know that number nope for me six
times was a charm and I said wouldn't it
be funny you're driving through the Deep
South and you are arrested for a murder
you didn't commit and the only lawyer
you can use is that guy great who my
cousin Vinnie so that was the basis and
I wasn't even a film major at the time
oh wow so later that became one of my
first movie ideas I was introduced this
comedian uh Sam Kinison and Sam Kinison
was really good with hecklers you know I
mean it would humiliate them and I
thought this would be fun for that movie
you know to have a lawyer who will
humiliate his Witnesses the ones he
needs to to beat up on then I got an
overall deal at Fox three picture deal
and at one point I had to go in and
Pitch something to him so pitched them
two stories the other was called Joe
safety and this one I don't know if I
had a title for it what would become my
cousin Vinnie what would become my
cousin Vinnie exactly so they picked Joe
Joe safety and I said I don't want to
write that one I want to write this one
he said okay okay so I wrote Finney the
the three picture deal at Fox so did
that start with Ruthless People and then
you started with Love Potion Number Nine
okay
and then I wrote my cousin Vinnie I
actually wanted to direct my cousin
Vinnie but they got the script and they
just now we need to make movies you know
I'm producer on it I did not have much
influence on that movie you know other
than the screenplay which is a huge
amount of influence when you were
writing it did you have uh actors in
mind for the characters yes and no it's
kind of a good rule not to do that
because then you're going to
pick up from something that they did in
another movie ah I'm trying to think
when I wrote it it's possible Robert De
Niro but there's also a friend of mine a
drummer in a band who's six foot five
scary looking guy sweet as can be
kind guy that's what I wanted for Vinnie
Vinnie is supposed to be six foot four
possibly an ex-boxer and a guy who is
smarter than he realizes he's not sure
he is smart largely because he's
dyslexic but the idea he was supposed to
walk into a courtroom and actually be a
kind of scary looking kind of a scary
looking guy I mean if he was six foot
five if you six foot eight it would have
been great you know and a guy who talks
like this you know so I couldn't really
pick out one actor that suits that
because Robert De Niro is I don't know
what 5 10 or 5 11 you know he is not a
big towering scary looking guy but he
can look tough you know so we had a
meeting about casting and so who's your
first choice for Vinnie and I said
Robert De Niro
and Roger birnbon did this he did this
you know it's just De Niro's movies they
don't make money and he's not funny
but later they came up with Joe Pesci
and I said well he's not wrong for it
you know but I just imagine somebody who
was like six foot four so I did not
think Joe could be an intimidating
character but he was cast and then
Goodfellas came out I was going to ask
yeah whether that preceded or post-dated
Goodfellas proceeded it by a few months
you know I think I don't know but it was
but but then when he saw that I get okay
okay forget that yeah he he can pull
that off you know I I can understand the
impetus to want this sort of
stereotypical giant you know leather
clad bouncer New Yorker type yeah I
think it's kind of funny to go with the
complete opposite direction of like five
five five six Joe Pesci yeah it's still
a fish out of water yeah you know I mean
that's that's the guy he talks like this
in the in the South you know do I have
to kill you what if I was just to kick
the ever-loving out of here that's
still what what's what makes it work I
mean in my mind look just to make sure
he's dyslexic that got cut
in the movie Vinnie is kind of
floundering kind of flounder and then
there's a certain point where he's not
slandering anymore right exactly it's
explained more if you understand he's
dyslexic
if you know he's dyslexic and then the
next scene the judge gives him a book
that thick on Criminal Court procedure
in Alabama read it over the weekend yeah
you know if I can disagree with you so I
asked to wait
oh go ahead okay the the way that it's
cut in the movie is uh the the
explanation Vinnie gives is between your
father's garage your working nights when
was I supposed to go yeah and that's the
reason why he can't study for the bar
which from my perspective is as a lawyer
that makes perfect sense you go to law
school you graduate knowing basically
nothing about the law or practicing and
then ideally you would spend the next
five months studying for the bar yeah
unless you go into the big firm world
where they will give you a stipend to
cover your living expenses you know you
have to make a living you gotta You
Gotta Eat to me in my mind I conflated
all that together and it made a perfect
sense for why he took the bar so many
times it didn't pass and also why he
doesn't have any actual experience yeah
as a lawyer yeah but it ain't no big
deal the movie does not
not work because of that uh this this
Lexia was was also a little part of the
character he had a certain element of
Pride there and didn't you know wanted
to win the case by himself but the very
very end of the movie you know he you
know he's won the case you know that's
good and then he's a little disappointed
you know I was you know doing all by
myself you know she's oh my God what if
you win case after case you never lose
but at the end you have to thank
somebody what a nightmare right oh my
God what a nightmare this is funny you
know but that that's who his character
is or was anyways after I had written
the script turned it in one of the
executives
present in the studio said good work
very funny good job
do you think you could cut the character
of Lisa out of the movie
I said you just honed in on maybe the
best thing in the movie and asked me to
gut it out and the Oscar goes to Marissa
in my cousin
so then he said well you know she has
some really good lines at the end I said
yeah but uh I said but Vinnie has to
know all that information
to know to put her on the stand
because a lawyer should not be asking
questions he doesn't know the answer to
that's very true and so when he puts her
on there
and he describes his case and he says
does the defense's case hold water and
she looks at the pictures and says no
well that's outrageous I mean how would
he put her on there and intentionally
have her to say you're wrong
but then she realized there was
something there and they have an even
stronger case yeah this is your opinion
it's a fact so it was a nice it's
definitely a movie moment you know
you've been a lovely
lovely Witness
so I did some research I flew down to
New Orleans picked up a rental car drove
up the Mississippi stopped off in
Jackson stopped off in
I don't know it was Wazoo or something
Mississippi is some funny name we're in
Wazoo it's in Beacham County Alabama Ma
and then I I drove East
into Alabama I stopped off in a city
called Butler small town
and I knocked on the door and I spoke to
an assistant district attorney there and
he looked like an actor I knew named
Lane Smith
and Lane Smith ended up playing the
prosecutor in my cousin Vinnie yeah I
was talking to him and in his office he
had some like I know stuffed fish or a
couple of stepdads or something like
that and a lot of the stuff that he said
went right into the movie that says you
know he was tired of you know getting
good guys off you don't want to put some
bad guys behind bars right well that's
what I've been doing and uh I'm a
happier man for it now my cousin Vinnie
famously involves two kids who really
need a good lawyer but they have to call
their untested cousin luckily for you
you don't have to take your chances on
the closest person you know you can come
to me in my Law Firm the eagle team if
you or a loved one is seriously injured
we can help a free consultation is just
a phone call away if you want Eagle team
on your side the link is in the
description below I remember going to a
restaurant there and on the menu on the
chalkboard chalkboard rather than tell
you you know was it fried chicken and
collard greens or something it just said
breakfast lunch dinner
it's all ahead you know so that goes
into the script I remember breakfast
yeah good choice
two I was going through a cholesterol
issue you know and sure on the griddle
the guy puts in a bunch of Crisco or
something and then he says are you aware
of the cholesterol problem in this
country you guys down here hear about
the ongoing cholesterol problem in the
country everybody's very friendly but
everybody's also concerned uh about
being portrayed by Hollywood as a
redneck or a hick well I thought it
would great be great to make it a
different otherwise that's a little bit
of hackery
um not only making worth it making that
part of the plot
and so what was great with the judge who
had gone to Yale a very good law school
this is not the Forum to be Cavalier he
is a little sensitive by how Southerners
are portrayed in the north but what we
do have is every bit of sophisticated a
system of justice as they do in the rest
of the country and lets him know that
we're down here we're going to stick to
the letter of the law that bad you said
when you come into my courtroom you
would know the letter of the law
I'll react harshly when you don't which
is great and sets up the movie because
Vinnie doesn't know what he's doing
right and the judge says I'm going to be
tough on you yeah because he's assuming
this guy you know comes from a place
where he's going to look down on yeah
the only being from New York you're
gonna get a special treatment I
shouldn't part of what makes it so
enjoyable is that they're facing
adversity but they're not facing a like
an evil person or a bad guy and part of
what I think makes my cousin Vinnie such
a great portrayal of all the characters
is that as you said the judge he's not a
bad guy he's not out to punish anyone
yeah he just wants his courtroom to
affect Justice I
really thought I was doing something
interesting in there by not having an
antagonist and I made a point of that
when I wrote it I would love to hear
this
so would I I can see the director fell
to the temptation
of making that a little fungible
and so I was very sensitive to where
let's say the prosecutor was getting a
little aggressive does that mean that
you can't answer it's a
question it's impossible to answer
impossible because you don't know the
answer nobody could answer that question
little obnoxious when they put Lisa on
the stand you know and he's
this is he was a little too much I would
have liked to pull back on that
objection can we clarify to the court
whether the witness is stating opinion
or fact I think Lane Smith played it
perfectly I think he did a great job
that's a question about that the
director might have pulled it back a
little bit so and so we can see uh he's
skeptical but rather than tackling yes
yeah that's all that's all I just make
it a little more subtle
no objection your honor well let's talk
about how you were able to make such an
accurate legal film
um yes good point I have to imagine you
talk to some lawyers you talk to the
assistant district attorney anyone else
quite crucial in this and very important
is I have a an old friend named Doug
Knoll who was from my high school I
would meet with Doug and I would ring my
laptop he was a litigator so I asked him
questions and I remember asking him
which
course in law school do they teach a
procedure they don't that's true really
yeah
I mean I think I lit up at that point
and I said well where do you learn it
he says either the Herm firm that hires
you or you go to court and you watch
really yeah so I wrote that down it's in
the movie verbatim as he told me didn't
they teach that in law school no that's
not what they teach you they teach you
contracts precedence interpretations and
then the firm that hires you they teach
you procedures or you could go to court
and watch and that's becomes the
structure of the story so I would ask
him but what if he does this what if he
does that you know and because I never
really knew exactly what the format is
so I figured let me most people don't
yeah and most people who write movies
about courtrooms don't correct now that
you've seen my cousin venue now that
I've written it you know that's wrong
right you don't do that right you can't
say that you can't get up and walk over
there you can't do all this stuff no
this is ridiculous you know and in
comedies it gets worse and worse and
worse you know so the idea this is a
comedy and it's accurate it's great it's
kind of a twofer who might have the
impression at law is
practice with a certain degree of
informality down here
it isn't when I remember asking him you
know and then what happens well you know
there's the opening statement you know
and the prosecutor presents his case he
may show some evidence and this and that
in the united sat in court listen to
them and I realized you you have to make
it not even a tenth the size you know
yeah I mean real trials go on for days
and days and days yeah the opening
statement might take an entire day oh
yeah yeah yeah so you have to find a way
to convince that you know and so then
Vinnie's got to go up and basically say
everything that guy said he said yeah I
said I think I'll have any say that he
laughed you know and it's a fantastic
line yeah and it works because he
doesn't know what he's doing quite yet
yeah and of course he's falling asleep
because he can't get any sleep yeah
says
and I gotta tell you I mean that's one
of those lines that every lawyer wishes
they could say yeah objection Yana
council's entire opening statement is
argument objection sustained there's so
much of the movie that gets the Nuance
of the legal practice right for example
if you have the tire expert who uh comes
in who is the the surprise witness I'm a
special Automotive instructor of
forensic studies for the Federal Bureau
Investigation you set that up in a way
that's pretty close to what you have to
do with real experts is that something
that you talked about or did you just
Intuit that that's how you lay the
foundation I think a little bit of both
I also had a
I would call it misspent youth in high
school where I was a car nut and when I
was 16
I could tell you the engine displacement
horsepower configuration carburation
weight and any engine option of every
single car sold in America I just I just
love that I was fascinated with it yeah
I I wanted to ask you I'm I'm kind of a
car guy less so now but but I used to be
really into cars and the movie is
legally accurate for the most part it
also it seems to be very automotively
accurate as well and that stuff came off
that I didn't do have to do any research
for that one is that right yeah well I
was going to ask you is the correct
ignition timing for a 1964 Bel Air with
a 327 and a four barrel carburetor four
degrees off of top dead center yes
in 1964 the correct ignition timing
would be four degrees before top dead
center well how did you come up with the
idea of the the piece of evidence that
was going to exonerate these two kids
were the the equally spaced tire tracks
and the fact that you know wasn't a live
axle when it went up on the curve
because there is
n't it by a 1963 Pontiac Tempest
exactly
you know I was a race car fan it was
more of a road racer and I had a Triumph
tr3 in 1958 little sports car I have
three trophies upstairs but you could
see you know you understood how
positraction worked you can see that if
you didn't have it like one tire is
going to spray off the drag strip right
yeah you really have to accelerate
slowly if you have this regular stock
differential what is positraction it's a
limited slip differential which
distributes power equally to both the
right and left tires so we've talked a
lot about the accuracy of the movie was
that something that was important to you
is that something that you actively
wanted to oh yeah yeah to me to me uh um
the authenticity gives me a direction as
a writer that every situation is an
opportunity and it becomes a more
interesting story and there's there's
always ways to make things funny what's
interesting about a case and interesting
about the law is both lawyers go into it
they know what the other side is going
to do if you show that in a movie and
nobody's ever really shown that there's
no story there you already know what the
story is going we know where it's going
Trotters files all of them you stole his
files there is a brief Montage where we
see Vinnie doing depositions but it's
brief because if we heard him everything
is going to be redundant you've heard it
before and the idea of bringing in a
witness last minute is frowned on
but if you're doing a movie every movie
every movie has a surprise witness
coming in every single movie it has to
and I think I have to do that and I have
to address that too you know they
brought in their witness so he can bring
in his
which is half the fun yeah more than
half the fun of the movie you can say
when she really desperately wants to
help because she sees them founding
around and it's frustrating for her and
it looks like he's losing the case
what's this you uh reading this book
yeah do me a favor okay don't read this
book
okay
thank you very much putting her on the
stand is a loving kind sweet act and and
it sprinkled throughout the movie that
that Vinnie is a car expert as well yeah
and and both of them have to have equal
knowledge to be able to come to that
conclusion at the same time yeah also in
the way they argue and that's the
dripping faucet scene is that a Drip by
here
yeah you can see that this is a playful
argument yeah that's it it's broken
you sure but you can also see this is a
cross-examination going on right right
and if they do this all the time right
maybe you didn't twist it hard enough
I twisted it just right for sport you
know it's gonna help sort of fine hone
his talents for cross-examination in a
courtroom yeah dead on bulls accurate
it's an industry term at the time or or
now are you familiar with uh Irving
younger's rules of cross-examination I
might have gotten a copy of that when I
wrote it because that sounds Vaguely
Familiar it's sort of the Bible of of
cross-examination okay and there are a
lot of things that are done in the
various cross-examinations that are
right out of absolute textbook correct
way of doing a cross-examination oh
interesting okay um and one of the
things that that is interesting about
the cross-examinations is you know even
if you are scoring points and destroying
a witness's testimony you don't want to
come off as a as a bad guy sure and and
you want to do it with empathy to the
position of of this witness because
they're probably just testifying the
best they know how yeah and and Vinnie
exemplifies that especially in the
cross-examination of the old woman with
the glasses he completely destroys her
testimony yeah I'm thinking of getting
thicker glasses but he's not the bad guy
yeah and and you feel a little bad for
the woman but it's not because he
destroyed her it's because she just
wasn't up to the task at the end she
seems sweet and and she could be wrong
you know it's just her glasses so he
doesn't need to embarrass her there's
one scene in there which I have been
told is now occasionally used in court
is the actor's name is rain or shine and
he's he's kind of a dim guy
and Rainer Shiner played him perfectly
it's maybe my favorite scene in the
movie what is this Rusty Dusty dirty
looking thing over your window
it's a screen someone told me that it
shows up in court that it's not uncommon
for people to use with an eyewitness the
apparently they came out of my cousin
Penny this dirty window
this crud covered screen
these trees I guess I would call it
um fact stacking that is absolutely
textbook that there's no way that he can
contradict what is this thing it's a
tree what is a tree covered in leaves
and it's absolutely perfectly logical
and of course it's a little simplistic
yeah but what you're doing is you're
making sure that the jury is hearing you
you're hitting it five ten times yeah
it's not the same thing because you
can't ask the same question over and
over again sure but you can ask the
series of questions that really hammers
home the points and that is honestly
that's it's one of the best portrayals
of of a good cross-examination that is
out there yeah great thank you thank you
it's fun to write you know it's fun to
write I suppose
I'm finished with this guy did anyone
ever consider doing a sequel of my
cousin Vinnie uh yes the the studio had
contacted me I came up with an idea Joe
and Marissa were on board
I was told and just before I finished it
I heard Marissa dropped out so well I
guess that plans moved what was the
premise of the sequel now there's the
screenplay version and then there's the
play version I turned it into a play
stage play so I'll give you the pitch
for the play version at least the First
Act okay because otherwise I can't tell
the entire thing the curtains open up
and we're in the Old Bailey and we see
Vinnie should come in from the back of
the theater
and he's carrying a brown paper bag and
Vinnie takes off his his jacket puts it
in the paperback and then pulls
something out of there which is a
Barrister's robe and then he pulls on a
Barrister's wig had to do research for
this right and
and again the research just comes up
with a lot of fun a lot of humor because
there's things Vinnie doesn't know
then the defendant is brought in and
it's Mona Lisa Vito I went to London to
do some research and I spoke with a
professor at Oxford I spoke to a
litigator I spoke to a high court judge
uh each one told me very clearly there's
no way you can get Vinnie in court but I
found a way to do it right and and do in
finding all the research just makes the
story richer and funnier and more fun
and you learn a lot about the core I'm
sorry the sequel didn't get made but uh
that I hope that the play does yeah yeah
he could I don't know it could it'd be
nice any other huge changes that the
studio or others wanted and that were
well forced in into the movie I did not
have the at the very end uh the actual
murder is being caught
a 357 Magnum Revolver was found in that
possession I thought that's that's
adding a little too much it's been sort
of sewing it up a little too neatly and
cleanly but that's not a movie I would
definitely want to remake because I
think it's a by and large uh done well
because mostly you've got you've got Joe
you got Marissa you got Fred win they
were great yeah hard to improve on that
yeah yeah I agree thank you so much for
your time uh if you haven't seen my
cousin Vinnie in a while go and watch it
it's one of the best legal comedies or
one of the best comedies of all time so
go out and and go watch Mike as Infinity
Dale thanks so much for thank you
telling all the secrets thank you that
was fun now there's a ton of additional
stuff that we covered in this interview
but you can
all through today's sponsor nebula
because all my videos go up on nebula
way earlier than on YouTube and often
include additional content and the
nebula version of this interview is
nearly twice as long it was a really
long uh wide-ranging conversation but on
nebul it's not just legal eagle there's
tons of exclusive content from tons of
creators it's the only place where you
can watch jet lag the game which is like
a better version of The Amazing Race
with YouTubers it's the only place where
you can watch new Lindsay Ellis content
it's the only place where you can watch
real life lore's modern conflict series
it's the only place you can watch
philosophytube AKA Abigail Thorns the
prince the only place you can watch
Patrick Williams feature link film night
of the coconut and it's the only place
you can watch my class on how to sue
like a lawyer and my documentary bad law
words good and that is just the tip of
the iceberg so if you'd like to support
creators and get access to all this
amazing content you can use my link
that's on screen right now or down in
the description and you'll get 40 off of
the annual plan which comes down to a
mere two dollars and fifty cents a month
so again to get a huge discount that
gets you access to all this amazing
content on nebula just click on the link
below and after that click on this link
over here for more legal eagle or I'll
see you you in court